go c'est en plongeant dans le répertoire
cajun que le futsal barbe a eu l'idée
d'adapter la pièce louisiane amène du
légendaire violoniste américaine tels
que chat on prenait le bateau qui sont
allés aux îles qui la chanson
[Musique]
georgia lé bras fiance redonner la
sortie mais gagner sa vie aux îles de la
madeleine
on a plus prigent la belgique
qu'est ce que lui disent and text le
texte a été adaptée afin de représenter
la réalité des pêcheurs des
îles-de-la-madeleine
on a senti besoin de se raccorder à nos
racines qui d'envoyer un message à notre
homme qui partait sur l'eau à tout les
gens qui vivent des produits de la
marque chas lui-même a donné sa
bénédiction au groupe en partageant leur
version sur ces réseaux sociaux
il a posté sur son web facebook day
disguise
ils viennent de faire une version je
suis vraiment honoré de la version
française qui ont fait de louisiane au
maine
chacun chez soi les musiciens ont
enregistré un vidéoclip sur leur
téléphone on était pris avec comme
pouvant faire produire vidéo pièces
comme ça avec le téléphone je trouvais
ça intéressant de le faire à la
verticale comme ça hop c'est simple les
communes spirit du comme il ya un esprit
de groupe quand même qu'ils ressortent
la pêche à la morue
la vidéo est parsemé d'imagés d'archivés
du film les îles de la madeleine de
maurice proulx et c'est pas dans votre
dieu stoffel et madame qui travaillent
dans les échoppes à poissons puis les
lego justement là dedans dans la vidéo
you une exemple d'une salle vert pour
ceux et celles qui savent pas quoi
exactement
c'est un filet de pêche comme on l'a
souvent du quai comme cela par les
reports de sa tournée a permis au groupe
de travailler sur un nouvel album dont
la date de lancement n'a pas encore été
confirmée c'était comme c'était une note
qui a comme martin bad de notes
aventures de faire de l'enrichissement
séparer on a pu comme bâtir une coupe de
gens sont là on est rendu à quelques
jeunes
je sais que dans les communiqués de
presse ils disent un album à la fin de
l'été c'est ce que jeff audi pis all in
web date faut juste qu'on sache qu
est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui va être
prêt lui aussi mais on va voir ce que
c'est que la forme que ça va prendre
salle barbe se croisent les doigts pour
un retour sur scène d'ici la fin de
l'été et qui sait peut-être un lancement
on aime papa
il s'est calé bordeaux radio-canada
menteur